so we just saw Jurassic world falling
Kingdom now that is one big pile of shit
you will remember to wash your hands
before you watch the third movie in this
series I doubt I will be right down the
first one to say that I really doubt I'm
the last
I had a Krusty the Klown moment right
when this ended I wanted a cigarette in
my hands and I just wanted to go what
the hell was that what is okay I'm still
trying to wrap my head around what I
just saw like I'm surprised there
weren't more pterodactyls in this movie
because this was batshit this is one of
those it's almost one of those so bad
it's good movies um it's just because
here's the thing the thing that stops it
from being bad is that the acting is
fine nobody's really a bad actor in
finance it's it's fine nobody's great
buddy but it's fine and and the dialogue
again is not good but it's like okay
they're just saying this to get to the
next thing to get to the next thing is
stuff like that but the choices made in
this movie and what they do with it it's
just the craziest goddamn shit and and
let's not forget that the end result of
all these choices is nothing okay we are
literally like only like with we're
basically at where lost world was this
is basically lost world their version
like we've been advanced like this much
this isn't a whole movie this is the
worst of all the Jurassic Park movies
anything that you worked at any of those
movies is right here focused on like
every scene I'm really not kidding like
every scene has a minimum of five things
you have questions about because they
make no goddamn sense what they're doing
why they're doing it sometimes who's
even doing it
history with the previous one because I
I liked it and you were definitely in
need not I kind of liked the beginning
and the end I don't think the middle I
thought was I I think now and I think
you agree with me that this movie makes
Jurassic world one look like Steven
Hawkings a brief history of time well
like that's a work of genius
I'm not impaired to this I I like
Jurassic world more than lost world I
never thought your ads across okay could
almost maybe I can use in our cake you
know something three everybody argues
about the Jurassic Park sequels let's
look let's try to compromise here Kim
can we all agree that sense the first
movie they've been kind of garbage II
like if we can all agree on that on that
baseline then we can all agree that we
have our own personal favorite piles of
garbage yeah like certain yeah certain
shit that you know speaks to a certain
trash we enjoy and we put on a little
garbage can lid and take the fork and
but everyone know me nothing's that's
good yeah and for me lost world was at
the bottom of the heat it was it was
boring it I hated it it was colorless I
liked Jurassic three just a little more
because it was mercifully short and I
love Sam Neill and he's one those actors
generation is the only thing I really
like in three is that I really do with
Jim and of all the sequels so far I have
like Jurassic world the most cuz a guy
gave me it was bright it was comfortable
gave me something I hadn't seen yet
which was the park fully functioning and
operational like the Death Star so a
great climax they had an awesome client
and then having awesome climax this way
like so until then I would have so lost
world was probably my least fair oh yeah
it's tough it's tough just because like
this one is more laughably bad yeah and
don't like whatever watch this one a
little more just cuz it's like worth a
good laugh but the more I thought about
it it is the same problem lost world
does where the whole middle part of the
movie is boring as hell so boring but
like they blow it
and here's the thing like the movie
trailer
hope he likes that movie trailer because
that is literally the movie you just saw
the movie beginning to end and there are
very few of any there's like one
surprise just like so than the trailer
saw them turns on the trailer
every suspenseful seed you know how it's
gonna come out because they did it in
the freakin trailer so alright I'll I'll
just say early on I'll say what's good
about this movie because it is literally
toothed it's very easy to play about the
first part was okay honey okay okay but
that ironically the part closest to us
oh yeah the guy who they're all going
like this the guys think why it's like
don't want to hear them to understand
what yeah yeah yeah this and then of
course what means you're gonna die and
come this way let me sing well he's
gonna be okay if he's going haha but
something that does time I was trying
you know I was just talking about the
whole island stuff the volcano blowing
up and all of that
look at the the way your scene was and
no anything with reviewing a dinosaur in
the shadows in a reflection hiding
behind something there's a good like six
or seven times they do it where I'm like
that was creative like and it's short
but I'm like you know I could see that a
Jurassic Park film this guy is like
trying to Ridley Scott this a bit like
and is there we go really bad no but but
I mean that and but here's one
compliment I will say is that the
cinematography sometimes I'm like 10 is
a glorious shot yeah there's a couple of
shots of like some guy walking there's
an under lit floor so the floor is white
and the Raptors kind of curled up almost
like the xenomorph and this guy's like
walking around and then the Raptors it
and I'm just like I feel like and the
way the movie plays out like it's hope
you like dinosaurs in a house like
that's pretty much the whole last half
dinosaurs in cages in a house and then
little bit of dinosaurs in a mansion
it's Dino Mansion yo guys man tours it's
mainly huh one you know a one and a half
if you count I feel like I almost feel
like this movie would have been better
if they just went for broke made it a
hard R and like cuz I feel like this guy
somehow wanted to have it be like alien
where it's like our aliens where it's
like the monsters have loosen you're in
an enclosed space and this and that and
I'm like okay but like it's all pg-13
we've seen there's very few it's I got
some guy gets an arm ripped up seen it
we die no swords do this shit already I
mean like in all the hell but okay the
other thing I like is that again you
can't see in the trailer that ball that
goes into the water there's this really
cool shot it's all done in one shot
where it's them trying to get out of the
ball while the water slowly Rises yeah
this area is the scariest thing in the
movie yeah browning not dinosaurs that
that was like putting my heart on edge
there yeah that was no suspenseful good
just cuz he was shot once I don't give a
shit soraa's never really scared me and
the funny thing is though best special
effect in the movie for my money was the
goddamn volcano I'm like this was the
line your step Dante's Peak I've ever
seen but when Chris Pratt's doing is mr.
bean impersonation like numbed up trying
to get up and the lavas like right here
I'm like okay I'm not like a volcano
expert but the lavas right yeah I said
feel like that all affected yourself
it's a good effect I didn't say that was
a good scene that was smart that was
like literally the movie stops he's like
tranquilizers or something wakes up in
the lavas coming towards him and like I
swear to God it just becomes guardians
of the galaxy it is like star-lord shit
he's like and like doing this whole mr.
beam routine tried to move out of the
way a beloved herb and I'm just like if
this weren't guardians of the galaxy
movie this would be hilarious but monk
what is this doing in this dinosaur
thriller like the movie is really goofy
no no kid no place the face really good
I was gonna say the opposite because
it's like I would be annoyed by that
scene cuz it's not funny but it's like
the closest thing to any comedy we have
in this I don't know
behind their just saying straightforward
lines no but you're right
unintentionally funny like the whole
movies just goofy is like you know what
we're gonna talk about later that was
goofy is yeah okay there's a lot of said
they do the computer program guy oh my
god
just took the t-rex like this is a guy
out of like overseas time no it was like
scooby-doo go go go go yeah it's
sprained himself with the bug spray
that's like he was literally just there
sort of look at images like it's like
okay like even the people they're
sending in like one has never worked on
the dinosaur and she's supposed to be
the one that's supposed to met it if
anything goes wrong she's supposed to be
the doctor one is supposed to be like
you could become pure program it's like
a paleo veterinary that's like gonna be
able worked out it doesn't know I've
never even seen the dinosaur there's
gotta be this damn park was open there
have to be people that know these things
can't understand the guy has met the
computer programmer is like what are the
t-rex is do a lot better to the t-rex
let him is like you know it's a medical
school and you have to know how to
operate on all sorts because yes so how
do you do that if you've never even seen
but yeah no I mean there's just like a
million things like that we are just
constantly saying wait why did they do
that what another good example via the
home alone with Dinosaurs there where
they're trying to go through and these
dinosaurs trying again this this girl
who's pretty much penny gadget she's
snooping around everywhere just why all
my god yeah oh man secret dinosaur
hideout brain so she's like sneaking
around this how is it you know age you
want to pray damn good job running away
from these things then it locks herself
in a room and freaking like hides under
the covers and I'm just like what you
were literally speaking out the house a
second ago hold on hold on so then this
dinosaur sneaks in so I'm like okay
she's gotta like hide under the covers
may entice her no she's just there
and like you could hid under the bed in
the closet anywhere else and it's just
for the trailer shop the dinosaur game
disco which again they already did in
lost world and Chris Pratt comes in you
know big girl doesn't die uh you know
Chris Pratt comes in saves the day he
doesn't even fuck him leave he his he
runs out Pilates the ball and guess
whatever goes up but get him a blue
comes in big shy okay no that's not a
spoiler I think they did show that too
but but she's like look at this time sir
under like these covers like still
looking right at him and Chris Pratt
runs out bullets of blue comes in she's
like here come with me out the window
I found this way okay just climb along
here okay and go down the drain I like
that is not the same kid who is hiding
under the covers a second ago that has a
totally different kid I know all the
characters are like enough what the
thing is your heads up girls really good
actress I thought I heard the characters
just not really written realistic it's
hard to tell first man who just like
admit she hides in this event like that
so Bob is here I'm like what bothers me
is how the fuck did that dinosaur just
like find him because like this shit
mana she ran away from this thing goes
up a dumbwaiter or something
sneaks into her room locks the door
hides under the covers like the the
window is closing it somehow this
dinosaurs like on the roof like like
goes down and I'm just like this is just
so many coincidence okay no know what
let's say let's really give this damn
thing the benefit of the doubt and say
it smelled or it sniffed around even
though it's in the rain everything let's
say that there are literally two other
instances where you know she's up on
this thing but humans are right down
here she's going yeah so that's dumb see
number one don't see number two right
after that scene because I'm like oh I
guess they can't smell yeah they they
they don't pick up scent right after
that scene a hind the clots in the
dancer literally goes down to angles and
by them well smelling them and it's like
the right bear like behind this very
thin wall it's like there's just a
million sees like
where you're just like but wait you said
there's and now you're doing that and
every scene every scene is like that the
science what fire things like even the
science in the first movies pretty
suspect and the decision yeah I have
decisions made in the first like the
first movies full of holes yeah yeah but
it tries it tries it still it is the
difference and the science has been
getting more and more just crazy and
like Jurassic world I'm just like
alright we don't even care about the
science here's a fun theme park there
you go
this one I think is actively like
murdering science whereas Jurassic world
was just ignoring science I think this
one is littering like we've got some
science II ideas here because you're
right the first one is essentially a
Disney film these are like Disney
characters you know going in like a
pg-13 science fiction film and but but
even Disney films have a humanity that's
why we still connect with them and said
it's like it's like a kiddie film but
there still is like humanity to them now
it just does not have any humanity but
if you're gonna make the science go
crazy that's fine
this was my problem with Jurassic world
now we have this new dinosaur we can
gene splicing great go to town with it
not are we gonna see then no yeah we get
that we don't get any we get a
boring-ass raptor soros racks is and
then you get in this one the exact same
goddamn thing except smaller like you're
just down sizing everything and even the
climax we were saying this when we're
getting close to the end I'm just like
oh my god like this is this is gonna
happen I said I sat there and I'm just
like and I put it together them like
this has to be the climax cuz we're in a
point in the movie where I'm like you
you can't go anywhere from here we have
decided that this movie is gonna be in
this fucking house the whole time for
some reason give me the Bible give lost
world that or yeah lost world that it it
went for broke and had a t-rex running
around San Diego I mean it was stupid
but it's like okay
now we have to honestly try on something
the next step now Nanjing lost world
only like a couple of raptors break into
somebody's home and the whole last 40
minutes of lost world is just these two
Raptors in this house that's this movie
like here's the funny thing too is that
this whole film I mean this film got it
felt over two hours this whole film it
fell long and it was going at a good
pace in the beginning yeah I thought
like all the stuff on the island there
was a pretty brisk pace to it I was like
yeah but you know this whole movie not
only doesn't need to exist but I can
we'll get to this in spoiler corner but
the last minute I just remember saying
why wasn't this the movie we were
watchin this is a huge step backwards
and only at the end is it doing
essentially what one of the other movies
did but Sir I take you to the next level
which is what we want to see we want
something taken to the next level and
this is not only a huge step backwards
it's like let's take everything that was
boring and stupid and nonsensical and
make no sense in the other films and put
it in this one I think the best metaphor
for this movie is that scene when
they're on the boat and you see this
like brontosaurus and they're all
watching sad and like this brontosaurus
gets engulfed by like the smoke and
flames of the volcano it's like
disappears into the clouds and it plays
like this sad Jurassic Park lame like
it's like dead and I'm just like there
there's your movie like this fella I
just saw Jurassic Park destroy here's
what these movies have been doing ever
since the first Jurassic Park and I
really think they're missing is that
with the first film you know it's the
science fucking with nature and it goes
wrong and it's great and there's really
no good guys or bad guys or anything
it's just science fucking with nature
and here's what happens and oh well
science goes this way nature goes that
way hopefully we won't let this happen
again we'll see a second film human bad
guy third film
what's our human big like every kind of
kind of grand citizen but mostly is our
trap in the air yeah
a human back fourth film vincit the in
Africa was a shitty human bad guy this
bill not only came a bad guy but doing
the exact same dumbass shit that the bad
guy in the last film did which was
already boring and they continued to
prom alike almost every single time to
continue the problem it's like we're
gonna do some with this Dino DNA we're
gonna weaponize them we're gonna and I'm
just like and like we never get farther
and just like here's a prototype in a
cage breaks loose kills a couple guys oh
no I want to see a freakin Jurassic army
tanks fantastic dinosaurs like more
easily watch the Raptor Newton just
these missiles with Raptor Rickon films
into this and like we still haven't gone
for it okay who's you know dr. Hammond -
pretty much uh well plannin - and then
the blue ever that bad guy was in lost
world the little wormie business guy
Hammonds assistant he's got a
doppelganger in this movie cuz he yeah
bad guy in this oh and dr. Wu the only
thing that was making me laugh I'm just
like you know what you could bring this
guy in screen all that nice guy for the
first felt just suddenly be a villain
was kind of fun
oh now every time I watch the first room
he's gonna be like velociraptors even
cracks the tiniest moans Berenice
there's evil okay so this energy I'm not
giving anything away cuz this is in the
trailer uh you know dr. Hammond to is in
this giant house and there's this giant
auction going on in the basement this
gigantic basement where's all these
pages and all the scientific equipment
where they do their Dino splicing and
all this stuff again Impaler no and he
has no clue I know this guy he's sick
and he's dying everything by his no clue
all this stuff is happening literally
hidden here stuff he didn't like he
doesn't count like oh hey well what's
this code on the elevator hey what's
this button that can easily push to get
down what's those warring sounds I hear
in the bowl
so many things that don't make sense
I'll tell you what doesn't make sense of
me what bothers me is the behavior of
some of the dinosaurs like they do they
do it just for Hollywood moments I get
it haha the t-rex roars and the sign
comes down and that's good but like when
they're escaping in the ball and then I
was an Allosaurus it was some some big
predators spinosaur some some some eat
you Soros comes and is gonna like eat
Chris Pratt and these guys the fuck
asaurus rex and like out of nowhere and
there's a volcano lie clearly in an ash
cloud coming all the geysers and running
away yeah what you seen the trail of
rocks falling I don't know where t-rex
comes as Chris Pratt's about to be get
like get eaten like like takes this
predator dies I think like plops it down
and the T Rexes looks at it and then
takes off and this is like like what was
going through that t-rex's thought
bubble just like I'm running away but
fuck this guy you just and I'm just like
why if these dinosaurs is so panicking
why does this t-rex take the time to
save crisper I was like did the t-rex
just turn around and be like now we're
even
and then like and then the grooviest the
goofiest scene I swear to God like
randomly like they wake up on the beach
and then you see this helicopter is this
t-rex just lying down then this leg
gurney just obvious you saw like how all
the work they had to go through there
pretty much king d's like you know yeah
they've got snakes people just get this
little ones Raptor you know they they
finally give this one wrap and that's
volcano glow all the dinosaurs are
falling off this cliff and everything
it's just well I guess they're all dead
and he's like well not all I mean you
just see this blue this t-rex wing that
dis is below the helicopter processors
there's a turret they're like they're
all yeah
looked so funny and like that was the
first time like we're in trouble cuz
like I was laughing so hard at that cuz
I just I just like I was just imagining
you know I totally forgot I swear to God
no I don't care this is a giving up
anyway it's really not but okay so there
I was trying not to laugh is there's a
scene where one of the dinosaurs you
know is in a cage the spoiler it's got
to get out and this guy is going over
thinks he's knocked it out and he looks
over it yeah
the dinosaur is pretending yeah but then
the tail is like almost yelling ten feet
yo shoulder and he turns out the
dinosaur literally opens his eye at the
crime and his smile looks at the cameras
like like like a real beavis and
butt-head smile just wait for an
audience literally a cartoon yeah I
couldn't believe what in the audience
like laughed and it was that nervous
laugh of like oh yeah the behavior of
the dinosaurs makes no sense I love the
stupid things of just like hey let's
take the bullheaded dinosaur and put it
in a brick wall that I can knock over
like yeah there's no thought implicating
these damn things but a guy behind us
was loving at the end when dinosaurs
break loose you know big surprise like
people getting tossed around whenever
there was a major Daffy Duck he was the
only one who wanted the theater was
stone-cold silence and the Bears ago
yeah no I have my favorite though was so
they said our cinema now they sell pizza
so my wife got like a little personal
pan like you know Pete I guess it's
pizza huh yeah
and so she's like I can't finish this do
you want the last slice I'm like no so I
gave it yeah yeah yeah
so I give it to Doug and he's like all
right so he's starting to eat it the
same guy behind us discuss hey hey do
they allow you to eat pizza here does it
yeah like they sell it right over there
that's really cool because I've got a
t-rex eyes apatite just had this look at
your face and you look like Dennis Nedry
like pulling yourself back to the tow
line after your face like it's awesome
he was talking all throughout the
trailers to me I was just like okay if
he doesn't do the film I am gonna turn
he was Joe's mostly quiet during the
film except in the action sequences more
entertaining than the movie yeah here's
the other thing too that feel like these
movies are trying to do and the only one
that did it well was the first one
because it didn't maybe did hammer it in
but did hammer it in like the sequels
and that's okay we're running away from
these things but we're supposed to care
about these things we're supposed to
want to take care of them I give it like
this would you call me an animal hater
and frickin did they stainless brace
Houston Austin how her whatever her name
is and Chris Pratt and all these other
idiots like Joe so this volcano is gonna
erupt on this island killing all the
dinosaurs and goblins pretty much like
look this this is an act of God senator
Brian ACK we shouldn't up and now God's
gonna wipe them out just I think we
should I think we should let them die oh
yeah no I don't like I realize I'm not
gonna win it is easier here but if this
was the first attempt
and trying to control these things
but there's already like three or four
blown-up islands aren't there because
it's another 1/3 island something all
I'm saying here is that I was at the
theme park when I blew up the first time
and I went back to the island where
numerous friends of mine were killed and
a t-rex escaped into San Diego and then
my other friend crash-landed on the
island where more people were killed and
he barely escaped with his life and then
the theme park which I was thoroughly
against I might add also just blew up a
few years ago so watch it's not the
fuckers dying has it ever worked out
trying to save the dinosaurs no no
running away from them has turned out
fine they were already staying and it's
one of the things where it's like the
second film tried to do it it sucked
I don't think the third film tried to do
it again the third feels kind of its own
just run away from dying in that's it
yeah the Jurassic world tried to do it
it sucked and now this one's trying to
do it and it sucks we always know what
it is is that humanity is gonna be the
dicks and then we shouldn't fuck with
the dinosaurs
so what are we always fucking with the
dinosaurs like the good guys are always
going in to fuck with the dinosaur hey
screen junkies add somebody retire when
it was like and that was the last time
anybody decided to ever mess with
dinosaurs so anyway they built another
Park it like it keeps going on and on
with every sequel but that was the last
time and then that way I can fall in
Kingdom but okay the big problem is that
again with the first one you it really
took a while to it again just I know
it's like it does me feel but it's like
structured so well and they you had the
little preview with the dinosaur eating
the guy the opening but then like you
really have just this magical whimsical
holy smokes there they are dinosaurs and
you feel the people looking at them and
they're they gave me something a hint
and it mainly took a long time to you
know so yeah but there's this dread
maybe and then when that t-rex comes in
and become survival like man did that
just feel like that went so naturally
into that which as you're talking about
now Oh
Jurassic Park okay but that's the
problem since the reboot sometimes I
think Jurassic world when people say the
first film I mean so well and all the
other movies always open with them doing
something bad they really never captured
the incredible size of magic of seeing
them the first time oh you all had the
same damn intro to of like here's to
people you haven't seen before who about
ready to get attacked by a dinosaur and
then we're gonna have a main credit
sequence oh by the way the credit the
logo and this made me laugh because it
was just like music is going like you
know oh for two and I was like whatever
it is music yeah like you've never seen
hummina swords before the supposed to be
like whoa I feel the size of this man I
mean just took the fifth movie to
finally get this going but yeah whoa no
dinosaur yeah no in the home the whole
plot it just it made no sense cos like
unless maybe was trying to be like has
stupid Millennials trying to save deines
but then the way thing is there's like
an anti-trump shot like here there and
there's - well yeah but what is funny at
the very bottom the very bottom it says
you as president questions whether
dinosaurs even existed that was funny
but then you're right they hammered hard
with these like nasty woman I'm like
okay shut up your thing is the whole
like your quote-unquote heroes of the
story are fucking animal rights lovers
and idiots who basically have now
probably doomed humanity like I don't
like what is what is your point
man yes your point and like see that's
where we're smart we're playing both
sides here we're not picking sides I'm
like no it's just dumb like yeah yeah I
don't care just pick a side like yeah
the when we get those like weightless
corner depending I love this movie I am
really like are you goddamn kid I like
are you really goddamn kidding me really
the last 15 minutes from then yeah
there's one big reveal in the last 15
minutes a family
are you but-but-but-but so the last
thing I think I'll get to I have to say
about is that we keep going back and
forth between we're scared of them we're
supposed to care about them and I feel
like we got that really bad in lost
world yeah lost world Jurassic world at
least again that opening captures soar
the wonder of the park and seeing them
you know but we know what's gonna happen
they're gonna break free is that but it
was really cool when you did capture
some of that magic cuz again know
something we never saw the park open so
that was really neat no so so so here
that's what I like that's what I liked
about when you're just flip-flopping so
badly between running away from these
damn things they're gonna kill you
they're gonna kill you in just oh no
they're dying like like you have done
nothing to make me feel anything you
made me feel a little bit for blue to
just that but that's a public just
they're dying a this beavis and butthead
but where I was like yeah I know what's
gonna happen I don't want to see them
get like tortured by humans but I'm just
like yes die they weren't meant to be
here like this was a mistake
yeah we're the ones the and it's like
yeah I don't want to see what you guys
me it's like we're clearly not exactly
what do you Malcolm said in the first
movie is happening in the beginning of
this once as I see their dinosaurs had
their chance now on this island the
nature D selected them by having a
dormant volcano suddenly become active
one wonders why John Hammond would build
a theme park on a volcano that could
erupt but it was dormant and now
magically sprang to life so it lays so
did their nature through the power of
lazy Hollywood screenplay was solving
the problem and like yeah no it was
actually I was actually kind of amazed
at how much this movie did not need to
happen like you were just perfectly say
cuz it's not like a merry rounds gonna
go in and do it it's like nature is
doing this and mankind over and over has
proven we are not able to you know do
these and
first film is doing nothing but proving
tonight I get all idea how to handle
Easton I guess the idea of you're stuck
bed guys coming in to steal some DNA
before the island blows if they want to
but the fact that there was a whole
movement of you know what honestly we're
just in a world of nothing but crazy
movements and all sorts of side so maybe
I'm not surprised but I'm just guys yeah
it's one of those things where it's like
yeah I was with you if they want to go
in and well first of all anything that's
down here would be dead already it's
like again how do know how does nobody
going in to just know any shit about
dinosaurs nobody does but they go in and
get this old bone they get some DNA and
it's like okay cool the the islands
gonna be wiped out and they're gonna
make new dinosaurs he'll make cooler
dinosaurs combine them all together make
something crazy they can't I know also
wrapped her and sews like a big
Velociraptor nice that was the pod to
the first one we can weaponize this and
he's training them Jurassic world yeah
just sorry Jurassic world with the he's
training them and they could be
weaponized why are we going so freaking
slow why can't we der and fast forwarded
three years it's like we snuck some off
the island and they're weaponize we're
gonna Miche them now yeah like this is
you just haven't moved at all like you
just you know it's like well now we're
gonna auction them off to be weaponized
who cares
it's like take a step don't take a
little baby step and be like oh my god
did you want other you want other
craziness Chris Pratt's building the
cabin in the woods by himself from
scratch in my family
I used to members like like he has it's
like he doesn't even have a freaking
nail gun he's building a cabin with
freakin two by fours with he's just
using a normal hammer away thunk thunk
and then there's this pile there's like
this chopped tree like this pile of like
chopped wood like you know still
circular I just the tree trunk in embeds
I'm like is he literally chopping the
wood to me who does this why did you
stab shit delivered if you want to build
a cabin five
just like and spend most my life living
in an Amish paradise raisin apart and
that won't end that's my reason I I
can't die I gotta finish my cabin I'm
surpluses I'm forgiven yeah so uh
something up and people have been asking
me they're saying like are you gonna do
a clipless review we are gonna review
this I feel like your prop guy it turns
out his wife just had a baby we want to
make sure he has time off and
congratulations to you but but but but
on top of that I wouldn't want to
because this one just has again every
scene just has so many things wrong with
it like I said it's just phenomenal how
every scene there is just no thought
everybody does the exact opposite of
what a rational thinking human being
would do where it's like I feel like I
gotta go over it seemed by Cena a
clipless I'm gonna be able to fit them
all in there uh so where I'm I was
telling him afterwards I'm actually kind
of giddy to review this smooth because
there's just so much to talk about we're
not even like touching the surface of
the dumb moves that they do so yeah I it
seems like all these Jurassic Park
movies like even just the worst ones
have their fans and have people that
like them I feel like these movies are
now entering transformers territory of
just being critic proof eventually they
will stop making enough money where
they're just like tho but like
transformers is like you could have like
a critical score of 30 percent people
still see it um that the last one out
that made people saw but they are still
making of all movie ways out
transformers yeah ya know but that's why
I'm saying but how long did it take to
get there
yeah took a while you know and that one
started more recently I said I don't
know I feel and like I feel like this
you what what a lot of people want take
it like if you like it
fine I guess like and that's a thing as
I said they've all been kind of garbagey
since the first one but my more fun
garbage yeah life to make the front yeah
to mine for my money the fun garbage was
dress
world and this is just garbage garbage
yeah this is just boring guy though this
is the closest to Laurel I guess I'm
still happen I don't know which one is
worse but but it's that same vein so I I
guess if you like lost world just take
out the part where the t-rex is in the
city and it's like that's kind of yeah
but it's the heart of the lawsuit yeah
but it in a house you know big house
there you go
but yeah it's um I still I still and I'm
being honest here can't quite wrap my
head around what I bet so and we'll talk
a little more about this boy whatever
yeah so uh oh man there's simply some
interesting things to talk about the
spoiler karna to my hair does I like
somebody I saw my describe this is like
well it's it's really goofy it's also
darker though and it's kind of like the
Empire Strikes Back I'm thinking more
attack in the clothing okay I think ever
talked about how it's just dark and and
kind of open-ended Allah is so maybe
like but that's a million times dark
doesn't mean good and it's not dark it's
shot dark it's not dark do you realize
not yeah not what okay I don't care for
this point now one good guy dies in this
nope none every Jurassic Park movie has
some sense some good purse I'll say
honest trailers pointed this out the
handler of the kids in Jurassic world
she went down the no Brad wait Lana I
was just like that was like probably one
of the most horrifying deaths I've seen
that a Jurassic Park movie or really for
a pg-13 film any movie
this is convicted part like an Oscar I
was like Jesus Christ like nothing in
this film I the funny thing is yeah when
those guys all showed up I'm like dead
dead dead and none of them I'm like I
can't tell if I'm like pleasantly
surprised or just disappointed I really
hope today were dying yeah they're a
color I might go away oh my god so yeah
you know if I don't know man I can't
figure out who I like this movie but
they all even as I said I liked Jurassic
Rome I know number of people are just
like it's
and Hitler so like I don't hate it that
much hello you internet him oh no I saw
like I there were people on my bed you
know people I've known who literally
it's just like did the director run over
your dog like what in like it was such
an overreaction so so yeah maybe this is
gonna be wow so I was like I really
don't like this movie and we're gonna
have people who's it's like so curious
well yeah I don't know what the
reactions like if you liked it but
please tell me what you liked about it
because like I'm legitimately curious
because it just doesn't seem like it's
giving what people would want to see I
guess the volcano like that was kind of
quite liked I liked the volcano and the
thing is I can't think of the you know
that that was gonna be the biggest scene
in the movie I thought wow well this is
what they're doing in the first quarter
of this film we're in for a wild ride
for the rest it was nothing yeah so yeah
and we were yeah it wasn't a huge ient
like it wasn't the giant disagreement
that you loathe drew it but we
definitely were disagreeing on that but
this game weren't total agreement yeah
so yeah I feel I could definitely tell
me why because I love to know because
like I said I just wasn't I wasn't
getting like what okay this is giving me
what a Jurassic Park movie kind of
promises and stuff you know and it's
both of us doing nothing new you know
what I'm adding anything I was most
interested when the dinosaurs are
fighting each other yeah you see they
would fight each other not much rather
just watch a whole movie you just set it
on the damn island and it's just like
here it's just the dinosaurs and they're
just fighting if we spent three hundred
million dollars on this and you know
what I'm fuckin watch you know I think
there's a Jurassic Park fighting game
where you just fight us yeah I was like
I would probably watch it was it just
get rid of the humans so um yeah you
know go see the movie or play that game
I've never played that game I'm curious
to try it up now I think the best the
best part for me and I remember turning
you and it's just Jeff Goldblum going
we've sat here and made the same mistake
again and again and again and we have
never learned our lesson I just turned
it was like is he talking to the
make her yeah like Hollywood like cuz it
just said he kept saying lines like that
it was like I I swear this is like some
sick in joke dad they're just talking
about the the creative team like but
whatever yes and he even he was like
even he was dull and I love Jeff go boom
at the end before I was actually looking
for dad and this movie is very very
restrained he had a couple of near the
end like the rising flies so yeah a
little dope boom came out it was good
it's like he had some like were you like
said it was maybe was crossing but it
came out came a river say we've reached
a critical crashing of these and the
voice would raise slightly in his speech
but I swear at the end he just had this
look on his face like what he says
exactly ladies and gentlemen welcome to
Jurassic world and he just the look at
his he's justhe's you're really paying
me to say this okay like can me my check
like it just was so like dead-eyed yeah
just lays he was so much fun anymore
yeah and he was fun in Jurassic Park I
didn't like was much in Los where I just
thought the character was written play
but it I look at it and this is another
problem I had with the series I look at
it I don't see this Jeff go boom here as
he and Malcolm I'm like this is some
different guy you could have told me
this was a different guy and I was like
cuz it doesn't seem like Ian Malcolm to
me it's like just sad tired and maybe
some point but it just isn't that
snoring like yes that's terrains that
the roman made of behemoths I wonder if
he's just like you know what I've been
ripping off this role for all my life
I'm just gonna go dead yeah you're right
this movie made me realize there was
more to Jeff Goldblum in Jurassic Park
yeah
Oh Tom I get credit for because you're
right it's like that doesn't feel like
that's the same person and he's not even
on spending that long so that's rightly
something it's the Sam's green my
christens I just want to look at was
like what had life do to you who hurt
you and who are you like because he's
just so like just I am dead inside and
it made me realize that cuz there's like
there's like a Easter Egg where I think
they it was that was supposed to be the
truck
at Timmy and Lex and an Alan Grant fell
over in that they find us yeah it's like
an upside-down truck with the old
Jurassic Park logo so I'm like haha it's
an easter egg that's the truck but it it
me realize just how much maybe this is
why I keep referring to Jurassic world
is the first film how I don't connect
this despite their best attempts to keep
trying to connect this to Jurassic Park
1 and loss well I don't I'm like I don't
see this as the same universe I kind of
wish it was just reboot and when they
show like the picture of him and the
painting I'm like I don't see him
existing in this like I don't see any of
this like I wish James Cromwell's
character would have been the Hammond
that created the park like it's not
Hammond but it's a different character
and this is a different universe and
because I just don't see the connection
hmm it doesn't feel like the same
universe to me and Mike and having Jeff
Goldblum should have just cemented it
for me I'm like that's not Ian Malcolm
yeah we're in a suit I don't care how
lowly is I want him in that fucking
leather jacket I say snipe on screen
fought for five minutes and you're right
it's like that's not him yeah so yeah
there it is
crap found away there it is fairness ha
ha you dig up dinosaur movies
Jurassic Park quote
you